protesters are filling the streets of
Puerto Rico's capital right now they are
continuing a week of demonstrations
demanding the resignation of the
governor there whose embroiled in a
social media scandal correspondent Jeff
Connor was in San Juan tonight good even
Jeff there are no signs of these
protesters slowing down they have that
out here all week as they can to the
Governor's House this spirited group has
been chanting singing and at times
marching all under the unified message
they want Ricardo Bofill gone the people
here are not only upset over the league
chats involving the governor and members
of this cabinet but there is a general
distrust for anyone involved in this
administration to leave them moving
forward at the end momento de lucha it
this is the time to fight this is the
time we are a country that is ready to
rise up we are ashamed and we will not
allow us Preston the governor has been
broken people do not believe in him and
if he had a drop of dignity he would
resign the governor here meanwhile
active today on social media he tweeted
out two pictures at least of himself
surrounded by some of his cabinet
members forbade no mention
protests already plans to resign but
some Democrats who are presidential
candidates for 2020 are now weighing in
the Buddha judge believes Castro tulsi
gabbard Kirsten Gillibrand betta award
Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren and
Marianne Williamson are some who tweeted
out their support for these protesters
we've seen comments that he and others
in the administration have made we've
seen them using force against the people
of Puerto Rico this governor can no
longer be effective and I believe that
he should resign president Trump also
tweeting about Puerto Rico just the
other day he said some bad things are
happening in Puerto Rico and that it was
foolish for Congress to give ninety two
billion dollars and hurricane relief but
according to federal data so far vo
Sagra says proved about forty two point
five billion for hurricane relief but
this island has only received less than
fourteen billion since May
Brett Jeff Paul live in San Juan Jeff
thank you